el alemán benjamin list fue recibido
como un héroe por sus colegas
científicos en alemania pocas horas
antes había sido reconocido junto al
escocés david macmillan con el premio
nobel de química ambos desarrollaron la
órgano catálisis asimétrica una
herramienta que permite crear nuevas
moléculas de una forma más barata más
simple y más amigable con el medio
ambiente el área en la que estoy
trabajando y en la que todos aquí en el
instituto están trabajando es la
investigación sobre catálisis los
catalizadores son extremadamente
importantes como tecnología para la
producción de casi todo lo que nos rodea
medicamentos colorantes artificiales
sustancias aromáticas plástico gasolina
todas esas cosas se producen con ayuda
de catalizadores de usted su trabajo es
concretamente con catalizadores
orgánicos que se han utilizado para
descubrir nuevos medicamentos la órgano
catálisis asimétrica facilita la
producción de moléculas asimétricas en
si estas moléculas tienen la capacidad
de ser mejor digeridas por los
organismos lo que hace que los
medicamentos sean absorbidos de forma
más natural
mcmillan profesor en la universidad de
princeton en eeuu también fue recibido
con festejos
sabíamos que sería más sostenible desde
el punto de vista ambiental eso fue algo
que nos preocupó especialmente desde el
primer momento hasta el año 2000 sólo se
conocían dos tipos de catalizadores
esenciales para crear moléculas las
enzimas químicas y los metales pero todo
esto cambió cuando listo mcmillan
descubrieron que con moléculas orgánicas
también se pueden catalizar reacciones
químicas que generan una contaminación
mucho menor